I've thought a long time about what
motivates behavior like that manifested
at Columbine and at Sandy Hook.
And then of course,
most recently at Parkland and because of
the Parkland event,
I thought that I would read a chapter
from my book to everyone.
It's chapter six rules six set your
house in perfect order before you
criticize the world,
and it's an extended meditation on the
kind of motivations that drive the
people who wished to slaughter innocence
as a form of revenge against God.
So I'm going to read it to you and you
can let me know what you think.
Rule six,
set your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world.
A religious problem.
It does not seem reasonable to describe
the young man who shot 20 children and
six staff members at Sandy Hook
Elementary School in Newton,
Connecticut in 2012 as a religious
person.
This is equally true for the Colorado
theater gunman and the columbine high
school shooters,
but these murderous individuals how to
problem with reality that existed at a
religious depth
as one of the members of the columbine
dual wrote,
the human race isn't worth fighting for
only worth killing.
Give the earth back to the animals.
They deserve it infinitely more than we
do.
Nothing means anything anymore.
People who think such things view being
itself as inequitable and harsh to the
point of corruption and human being in
particular as contemptible.
They appoint themselves supreme
adjudicators of reality and find it
wanting.
They are the ultimate critics.
The deeply cynical writer continues.
If you recall your history,
the Nazis came up with a final solution
to the Jewish problem.
Kill the mall.
Well,
in case you haven't figured it out,
I say kill mankind.
No one should survive.
For such individuals the world have
experienced is insufficient and evil,
so to hell with everything,
what is happening when someone comes to
think in this manner.
A great German play Faust,
a tragedy written by Johann,
both gang from Gerta addresses that
issue.
The play's main character.
A scholar named Heinrich Faust trades
his immortal soul to the devil.
Mephistopheles in return,
he receives whatever he desires.
We'll still alive on earth in girth.
This play Mephistopheles is the eternal
adversary of being.
He has a central defining credo.
I am the spirit who negates,
and rightly so for all that comes to be
deserves to parish wretchedly it were
better.
Nothing would begin.
Thus everything that your term,
sin,
destruction,
evil,
represent,
that is my proper element.
Girtha considered this hateful
sentiment.
So important,
so key to the central element of
vengeful human destructiveness that he
had mephistopheles say it a second time
phrased somewhat differently in part two
of the play written many years later.
People often think in the meth festo and
manner,
although they sell them,
act upon their thoughts as brutally as
the mass murderers of school college in
theater,
whenever we experience injustice real or
imagined,
whenever we encounter tragedy or fall
prey to the machinations of others,
whenever we experienced the horror and
pain of our own,
apparently arbitrary limitations,
the temptation to question being and
then to curse,
it rises folly from the darkness.
Why must innocent people suffer so
terribly?
What kind of bloody horrible planet is
this?
Anyway?
Life is in truth,
very hard.
Everyone is destined for pain and slated
for destruction.
Sometimes suffering is clearly the
result of personal fault such as willful
blindness,
poor decision making or malevolence.
Yeah.
In such cases when it appears to be self
inflicted,
it may even seem just people get what
they deserve.
You might contend that's cold comfort.
However,
even when true,
sometimes if those who are suffering
changed their behavior,
then their lives would unfold less
tragically,
but human control is limited
susceptibility to despair,
disease,
aging and death is universal,
and the final analysis,
we do not appear to be the architects of
our own fragility.
Whose fault is it?
Then?
People who are very ill or worse,
who have a sick child will inevitably
find themselves asking this question
whether they are religious believers or
not.
Okay.
The same is true of someone who finds
his shirt sleeve caught in the gears of
a giant bureaucracy who is suffering
through a tax audit or fighting an
interminable lawsuit or divorce.
Yeah,
and it's not only the obviously
suffering who are tormented by the need
to blame someone or something for the
intolerable state of their being
at the height of his fame,
influence and creative power.
For example,
the towering Leo tolstoy himself began
to question the value of human
existence.
He reasoned in this way.
My position was terrible.
I knew that I could find nothing in the
way of rational knowledge except the
denial of life and in faith I could find
nothing excepted.
Denial of reason,
and this was even more impossible than a
denial of life.
According to rational knowledge,
it followed that life is evil and people
know it.
They do not have to live yet they have
lived and they do live.
Just as I myself had lived,
even though I had known for a long time
that life is meaningless and evil.
Try as he might,
tall story could only identify for means
of escaping from such thoughts.
One was retreating into childlike
ignorance of the problem.
Okay.
Another was pursuing mindless pleasure.
The third was continuing to drag out a
life that is evil and meaningless.
Knowing beforehand that nothing can come
of it.
Yeah.
He identified that particular form of
escape with weakness.
The people in this category know that
death is better than life,
but they do not have the strength to act
rationally and quickly put it into the
delusion by killing themselves
only.
The fourth and final motive,
escape involved strength and energy.
It consists of destroying life.
Once one has realized that life is evil
and meaningless,
tolstoy relentlessly followed his
thoughts,
only unusually strong in logically
consistent people act in this manner.
Having realized all the stupidity of the
joke that is being played on us and
seeing that the blessings of the dead
are greater than those of the living and
that it is better not to exist.
They act and put an end to this stupid
joke and they use any means of doing it.
A rope around the neck,
water,
a knife in the heart,
a train.
Tolstoy wasn't pessimistic enough.
The stupidity of the joke being played
on us does not merely motivate suicide.
It motivates murder.
Mass murder often followed by suicide.
That is a far more effective existential
protest.
By June of 2016 unbelievable.
As it may seem,
there had been 1000 mass killings
defined as four or more people shot in a
single incident excluding the shooter in
the u s in 1,260 days.
That's one such event on five of every
six days for more than three years.
Everyone says,
we don't understand.
How can we still pretend that tolstoy,
I understood more than a century ago,
the ancient authors of the Biblical
story of Cain and Abel understood as
well.
More than 20 centuries ago,
they described murder as the first act
of post edenic history and not just
murder,
but fratricidal murder,
not only of someone innocent,
but if someone ideal and good and
murdered,
done consciously to spite the creator of
the universe.
Okay?
Today's killers tell us the same thing
in their own words.
Who would dare say that this is not the
worm at the core of the apple.
Okay,
but we will not listen because the truth
cuts too close to the bone.
Even for a mind as profound as that of
the celebrated Russian author,
there was no way out.
How can the rest of us manage?
When a man of tolstoy's stature admits
defeat for years,
he hit his guns from himself and would
not walk with a rope in hand and Casey
hanged himself.
How can a person who is awake avoid
outrage at the world,
vengeance or transformation?
A religious man might shake his fist in
desperation at the apparent injustice
and blindness of God,
even Christ himself felt abandoned
before the cross or so.
The story goes more agnostic or atheist.
Stick individual might blame fate or
meditate bitterly on the brutality of
chance.
Another might tear himself apart,
searching for the character flaws
underlying his suffering and
deterioration.
These are all variations on a theme.
The name of the target changes,
but the underlying psychology remains
constant.
Why?
Why is there so much suffering and
cruelty?
Well,
perhaps it really is God's doing or the
fault of blind,
pointless fate if you're inclined to
think that way and there appears to be
every reason to think that way.
Okay,
but what happens if you do
mass murderers believe that the
suffering attendant upon existence
justifies judgment and revenge as the
columbine boys so clearly indicated,
I will sooner die than betray my own
thoughts.
Before I leave this worthless place,
I will kill whoever I deemed unfit for
anything specially life.
If you pissed me off in the past,
you will die.
If I see you,
you might be able to piss off others and
have it eventually all blow over,
but not me.
I don't forget people who wrong me.
One of the most vengeful murderers of
the 20th century,
the terrible Carl Pans.
Ram was raped,
brutalized,
and betrayed in the Minnesota
institution responsible for his
rehabilitation.
When he was a delinquent juvenile,
he emerged enraged,
beyond measure as a burglar,
arsonist,
rapists and serial killer.
He aimed consciously and consistently at
destruction,
even keeping track of the dollar value
of the property he burned.
He started by hating the individuals who
had heard him.
His resentment grew until his hatred
encompassed all of mankind and he didn't
stop there.
His destructiveness was aimed in some
fundamental manner at God himself.
There's no other way of phrasing it.
Pans,
rem raped,
murdered,
and burned to express his outrage at
being.
He acted as if someone was responsible.
The same thing happens in the story of
Cain and Abel.
Cain sacrifices are rejected.
He exists in suffering.
He calls out God and challenges the
being he created.
God refuses his plea.
He tells Kane that is trouble is self
induced cane in his rage,
kills Abel God's favorite and truth be
known canes.
Idle Cain is jealous of course,
of a successful brother,
but he destroys able primarily to spite
God.
This is the truest version of what
happens when people take their vengeance
to the ultimate extreme,
okay.
Pans,
rams response was,
and this is what is so terrible,
perfectly understandable.
The details of his autobiography reveal
that he was one of tolstoy's strong and
logically consistent people.
He was a powerful,
consistent,
fearless actor.
He had the courage of his convictions,
how good someone like him be expected to
forgive and forget given what had
happened to him.
Truly terrible things happen to people.
It's no wonder they're out for revenge
under such conditions.
Vengeance seems a moral necessity.
How can it be distinguished from the
demand for justice after all,
after the experience of terrible
atrocity?
Isn't forgiveness just cowardice or lack
of willpower?
Such questions torment me,
but people emerge from terrible pasts to
do good and not evil.
Although such an accomplishment can seem
superhuman.
I have met people who managed to do it.
I knew a man,
great artists who emerged from just such
a school as the one described by pans
around only.
This man was thrown into it as an
innocent five-year-old,
fresh from a long stretch in the
hospital where he had suffered measles,
mumps,
and chicken pox.
Simultaneously in capable of speaking
the language of the school,
deliberately isolated from his family,
abused,
starved,
and otherwise tormented.
He emerged an angry,
broken young man.
He hurt himself badly in the aftermath
with drugs and alcohol and other forms
of self destructive behavior.
He detested everyone,
God himself,
and blind fate included.
Okay,
but he put it into all of that.
He stopped drinking.
He stopped hating.
Although it's still emerges in flashes.
He revitalized the artistic culture of
his native tradition and trained young
men to continue in his footsteps.
He produced a 50 foot totem pole
memorializing the events of his life and
the canoe 40 feet long from a single log
of a kind,
rarely if ever produced.
Now he brought his family together and
held a great potlatch with 16 hours of
dancing and hundreds of people in
attendance to express his grief and make
peace with the past.
He decided to be a good person and then
he did the impossible things required to
live that way.
I had a client who did not have good
parents.
Her mother died when she was very young.
Her grandmother who raised her was a
Harridan bitter and over concerned with
appearances.
She mistreated her granddaughter,
punishing her for her virtues,
creativity,
sensitivity,
intelligence,
unable to resist acting out her
resentment for an admittedly hard life
on her granddaughter.
She had a better relationship with her
father,
but he was an addict who died badly
while she cared for him,
my client had his son.
She perpetuated none of this with him.
He grew up truthful and independent and
hardworking and smart.
Instead of widening the terror and the
cultural fabric she inherited and
transmitting it,
she sewed it up.
She rejected the sins of her
forefathers.
Okay.
Such things can be done.
Neat.
You wrote these words,
distress,
whether psychic,
physical or intellectual need not at all
produced nihilism.
That is the radical rejection of value,
meaning and desirability.
Such distress always permits a variety
of interpretations.
What Nietzsche meant was this,
people who experienced evil may
certainly desire to perpetuate it,
to pay it forward,
but it is also possible to learn good by
experiencing evil.
A bullied boy can mimic his tormentors,
but it can also learn from his own abuse
that it is wrong to push people around
and make their lives miserable.
Someone tormented by her mother can
learn from her terrible experiences,
how important it is to be a good parent.
Many,
perhaps even most of the adults who
abused children were abused themselves
as children.
However,
the majority of people who were abused
as children do not abuse their own
children,
and this is a well established fact,
which can be demonstrated simply
arithmetically in this way.
If one parent abused three children and
each of those children had three
children and so on,
then there would be three abusers in the
first generation,
nine the second 27 the third 81 the
fourth and so on,
exponentially after 20 generations,
more than 10 billion would have suffered
childhood abuse.
Okay.
More people than currently inhabit the
planet,
but instead abuse disappears across
generations.
People constrain its spread.
That's a testament to the genuine
dominance of good over evil in the human
heart.
The desire for vengeance,
however justified also bars the way to
other productive thoughts.
The American English poet ts Elliot
explained why in his play,
the cocktail party,
one of his is not having a good time of
it.
She speaks of her profound unhappiness
to a psychiatrist.
She says she hopes all her suffering is
her own fault.
The psychiatrist is taken aback.
He asks why
she has thought long and hard about
this.
She says,
and has come to the following
conclusion.
If it's her fault,
she might be able to do something about
it if it's God's fault.
However,
if reality itself is flawed hell bent on
ensuring her misery and she is doomed,
she couldn't change the structure of
reality itself.
Maybe she could change her own life.
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn,
the great Russian documenter of the
abuses of Stalinism had every reason to
question the structure of existence when
he was imprisoned in a Soviet labor camp
in the middle of the terrible 20th
century.
He had served as a soldier on the ill,
prepared Russian front lines in the face
of a Nazi invasion.
He'd been arrested,
beaten,
and thrown into prison by his own
people.
Then he was struck by cancer.
He could have become resentful and
bitter.
His life had been rendered miserable by
both Stalin and Hitler,
two of the worst tyrants in history.
He lived in brutal conditions,
vast stretches of his precious time were
stolen from him and squandered.
He witnessed the pointless and
degrading,
suffering and death of his friends and
acquaintances.
Then he contracted and extremely serious
disease.
Soldier Knutsen had cause to curse God.
Job himself.
Barely had it as hard,
but the great writer,
the profound spirited defender of truth,
did not allow his mind to turn towards
vengeance and destruction.
He opened his eyes instead.
During his many trials,
Solzhenitsyn encountered people who
comported themselves notably under
horrific circumstances.
He contemplated their behavior deeply.
Then he asked himself the most difficult
of questions
and he personally contributed to the
catastrophe of his life.
If so,
how?
He remembered his unquestioning support
of the communist party in his early
years.
He reconsidered his whole life.
He had plenty of time in the camps.
How would he missed the mark in the
past?
How many times had he acted against his
own conscience,
engaging in actions that he knew to be
wrong?
How many times had he betrayed himself
and lied?
Was there any way that the sins of his
past could be rectified?
Atone for in the muddy hell of a Soviet
ghoulag
soldier knits and poured over the
details of his life with a fine tooth
comb.
He asked himself a second question and a
third,
can I stop making such mistakes now?
Can I repair the damage done by my past
failures?
No,
he learned to watch and to listen.
He found people he admired who were
honest.
Despite everything.
He took himself apart piece by piece,
let what was unnecessary and harmful,
die and resurrected himself.
Then he wrote the Gulag archipelago,
a history of the Soviet prison camp
system.
It's a forceful,
terrible book written with the
overwhelming moral force of unvarnished
truth.
It's sheer outrage.
Screamed unbearably across hundreds of
pages,
band and for good reason in the USSR.
It was smuggled to the West in the 1970s
and burst upon the world soldier Nixon's
writing utterly and finally demolished
the intellectual credibility of
communism as ideology or society.
He took an ax to the trunk of the tree
who's bitter.
Fruits had nourished him so poorly and
who's planting.
He had witnessed and supported
one man's decision to change his life.
Instead of cursing.
Fate shook the whole pathological system
of communist tyranny to its core.
It crumbled entirely,
not so many years later,
and soldier Nixon's courage was not the
least of the reasons why
he was not the only such person to
perform such a miracle.
Vaclav Havel the persecuted writer,
who later impossibly became the
president of Czechoslovakia.
Then of the new Czech Republic comes to
mind as does Mahatma Gandhi.
Things fall apart.
Yeah.
Hello.
Peoples have adamantly refused to judge
reality to criticize being to blame God.
It's interesting to consider the Old
Testament Hebrews in this regard.
Their travails followed a consistent
pattern.
The stories of Adam and Eve and Cain and
Abel and Noah and the Tower of Babel are
truly ancient.
Their origins vanish into the mysteries
of time.
It's not until after the flood story in
genesis that something like history as
we understand it truly starts.
It starts with Abraham.
Abraham's descendants become the Hebrew
people of the Old Testament,
also known as the Hebrew Bible.
They enter a covenant with Yahweh,
with God and begin their recognizably
historical adventures under the
leadership of a great man.
The Hebrews organize themselves into a
society and then an empire as their
fortunes rise.
Success breeds pride and arrogance.
Corruption raises its ugly head.
The increasingly hubristic state becomes
obsessed with power begins to forget
it's duty to the widows and the orphans
and deviates from its age.
Old Agreement with God.
A prophet arises,
he brazenly and publicly reviles the
authoritarian king and faithless country
for their failures before God,
an act of blind courage,
telling them of the terrible judgment to
come
when his wise words are not completely
ignored,
they are heated too late.
God smites is wayward.
People dooming them to abject defeat in
battle and generations of subjugation.
The Hebrews repent at length,
blaming their misfortune on their own
failure to adhere to God's word.
They insist to themselves that they
could have done better.
They rebuild their state and the cycle
begins again.
This is life
we build structures to live in.
We build families and states and
countries.
We abstract the principles upon which
those structures are founded and
formulate systems of belief.
At first we inhabit those structures and
beliefs like Adam and eve in paradise,
but success makes us complacent.
We forget to pay attention.
We take what we have for granted.
We turn a blind eye.
We fail to notice that things are
changing or that corruption is taking
root and everything falls apart.
Is that the fault of reality or God or
to things fall apart?
Because we have not paid sufficient
attention.
When the hurricane hit New Orleans and
the town's sank under the waves,
was that a natural disaster?
The Dutch prepare their dykes for the
worst storm in 10,000 years.
Have New Orleans followed that example?
No tragedy would have occurred.
It's not that no one knew the flood
control act of 1965 mandated
improvements in the levee system that
held back lake pontchartrain.
The system was to be completed by 1978
40 years later,
only 60% of the work had been done.
Willful blindness and corruption took
the city down.
A hurricane is an act of God,
but failure to prepare when the
necessity for preparation as well known
that's sin,
that's failure to hit the mark and the
wages of sin is death.
Romans six 23 the ancient Jews always
blamed themselves when things fell
apart.
They are as if God's goodness,
the goodness of reality was axiomatic
and took responsibility for their own
failure.
That's insanely responsible,
but the alternative is to judge reality
as insufficient to criticize being
itself and to sink into resentment and
the desire for revenge.
If you are suffering well,
that's the norm.
People are limited and life is tragic.
If you're suffering is unbearable,
however,
and you were starting to become
corrupted,
here's something to think about.
Clean up your life.
Consider your circumstances.
Start small.
Have you taken full advantage of the
opportunities offered to you?
Are you working harder on your career or
even your job?
Or are you letting bitterness and
resentment hold you back?
Drag you down?
Have you made peace with your brother?
Are you treating your spouse and your
children with dignity and respect?
Do you have habits that are destroying
your health and wellbeing?
Are you truly shouldering your
responsibilities?
Have you said what you need to say to
your friends and family members?
Are there things that you could do that
you know you could do that would make
things around you better?
Have you cleaned up your life?
If the answer is no,
okay,
here's something to try.
Start to stop doing what you know to be
wrong.
Start stopping today.
Don't waste time questioning how you
know that what you're doing is wrong.
If you're certain that it is in
opportune questioning can confuse
without enlightening as well as
deflecting you from action.
You can know that something is wrong or
right without knowing why you're entire
being can tell you something that you
can neither explain nor articulate.
Every person is too complex to know
themselves completely and we all contain
wisdom that we cannot comprehend.
So simply stop when you apprehend
however dimly that you should stop.
Stop acting in that particular
despicable manner.
Stop saying things that make you weak
and ashamed.
Say only those things that make you
strong.
Do only those things that you could
speak of with honor.
You can use your own standards of
judgment.
You can rely on yourself for guidance.
You don't have to adhere to some
external arbitrary code of behavior.
Although you should not overlook the
guidance of your culture.
Life is short and you don't have time to
figure out everything on your own.
The wisdom of the past was hard earned
and you're dead.
Ancestors may have something useful to
tell you.
Don't blame capitalism.
The radical left or the inequity of your
enemies.
Don't reorganize the state until you
have ordered your own experience.
Have some humility.
If you cannot bring peace to your
household,
how dare you try to rule a city.
Let your own soul guide you.
Watch what happens over the days and
weeks
when you were at work,
you will begin to say what you really
think.
You will start to tell your wife or your
husband or your children or your parents
what you really want and need.
When you know that you have left
something undone,
you will act to correct the omission.
Your head will start to clear up.
As you stop filling it with lies,
your experience will improve.
As you stopped distorting it within a
authentic actions,
you will then begin to discover new,
more subtle things that you are doing
wrong.
Stop doing those too.
After some months and years of diligent
effort,
your life will become simpler and less
complicated.
Your judgment will improve.
You will untangle your past.
You will become stronger and less
bitter.
You will move more confidently into the
future.
You will stop making your life
unnecessarily difficult.
You will then be left with the
inevitable bear tragedies of life,
but they will no longer be compounded
with bitterness and deceit.
Perhaps you will discover that you're
now less corrupted soul,
much stronger than it might otherwise
have been,
is now able to bear those remaining
necessary minimal in escapable
tragedies.
Perhaps you will even learn to encounter
them so that they stay tragic,
merely tragic instead of degenerating
into outright hellishness.
Maybe your anxiety and hopelessness and
resentment and anger,
however murderous initially will recede.
Perhaps your uncorrupted soul will then
see its existence,
a genuine good as something to celebrate
even in the face of your own
vulnerability.
Perhaps you will become an ever more
powerful force for peace and whatever is
good.
Perhaps you will then see that if all
people did this in their own lives,
the world might stop being an evil
place.
Okay.
After that,
with continued effort,
perhaps it could even stop being a
tragic place.
Who knows what existence might be like
if we all decided to strive for the
best?
Who knows what eternal heaven's might be
established by our spirits,
purified by truth,
aiming skyward right here on the fallen
earth.
Set your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world.
Okay.